[Music]
focus
okay sorry alright some important points
about your in and out points on the four
quadrants of your imaginary circle which
will make all of this split time
opposite stuff easier so the point of
these points is that in these positions
the middle positions when the hands are
up and down and in each side it helps to
develop a real sense and skill with
having the play on the out points and
the in points this goes for the top and
bottom middle and for either side the
poi can be out or they can be in and you
want a feeling for that because that's
going to help you a gain scale with the
different formations you can make so the
easier ones are at the side on either
side you can have a feeling for when the
poi are away at the out points and when
they're almost touching your chest at
the endpoints and just get a feeling for
that away in a way in a way in same on
the other side away in a way in a way in
an ideally poi spinning inwards and
outwards people tend to get a little
more stuck on this one because in the
beginning they go into a same time so it
really takes a while to get a clear a
clear split time or the poi you're going
to be brushing noses every time as they
pass in the middle you can play with
making your hands go up and down or side
to side or circling all of those will
help but if you want to go down this
wonderful role of split time opposite
flowers in a wall plane you need this
and there's no way giving around that so
it will come just with practice but it's
worth directly practicing it so you can
push away in a way in a way in or right
left right that's right I find a way in
easier and again you want a feeling for
the away points and the endpoints
in in in
away away away way in this version the
purpose in in in in in in in in in on
each quadrant the poi are pointing
towards the center on this version the
power away away away away away away away
away away away away away they put away
at each quadrant and if you want to make
combinations this it's going to be a
combination of which poi points in and
which point points away for instance at
either side to play a point in point in
point in both in both in both in both in
but the top and bottom one points in and
one points away now we'll go through the
formations and we'll get more in the
detail on that but they get prepared get
a feeling for in a way in a way in a way
both directions in a way in a way in a
way and make sure you're not doing this
in a way you know way you want the poi
really stacked you in a way in a way you
know way so once you have that little
arsenal of being able to feel and see
the in and waypoints in the middle with
either hand on top and then either side
boy going inwards or outwards we're
ready to proceed to all the different
patterns away
[Music]